so here's a controversy I missed over
the break uh this is from last week and
U maybe you heard about it or maybe you
value your own sanity so you instead
took a break from news and social media
over the over uh Christmas uh and didn't
hear about whichever the case Nikki
Haley got herself into trouble because
of an answer that she gave at a town
hall um about the Civil War well the
town hall was not about the Civil War
but there was a question about the Civil
War I don't know why this question was
asked I mean I don't know why
you know you have a chance to ask a
question to a presidential candidate and
you're asking him about a historical
event from 150 years ago I'm not sure
why that would be your question but it
was and
um and the question was specifically
what was the cause of the Civil
War and here is what Nikki Haley came up
with on on her first try and there were
many more tries after this but here was
her first try let's
watch um what was the cause of the
United States Civil
War well don't come with an easy
question or anything I mean I think the
cause of the Civil War was basically how
government was going to run the freedoms
and what people could and couldn't do
what do you think the cause of the Civil
War
was I'm sorry I'm
not I to the
I mean I think it always comes down to
the role of government we need to have
capitalism we need to have economic
freedom we need to make sure that we do
all things so that individuals have the
Liberties so that they can have freedom
of speech freedom of religion freedom to
do or be anything they want to be
without government getting in the way
thank you and in the
2023 that question without mentioning
the word
slavery what do you want me to say about
slavery
next
question okay um so she did not say that
the Civil War was caused by slavery and
then she was asked about it's kind of
hard to hear what the guy's saying
exactly but you can take context clues
uh she was asked again about slavery and
then she says next question like she's
trying to dodge it like she's like she's
afraid to just say slavery is a terrible
thing but it's awful I'm opposed to
slavery I don't like put me in the anti-
camp when it comes to slavery uh she
don't want to say that so it's said she
said next
question um and this set off several
days of controversy and outrage the
corporate media and the and also the
establishment right uh usually defend
Nikki Haley you know usually they're big
Nikki Haley fans but on this one uh they
turned on her and they went after her
and so over the next few days she made
multiple attempts to kind of clean up
the mess but she really didn't make
things much better for herself so here
she was uh I think this was a day later
and uh here she is addressing the
controversy and sort of trying again
with an answer let's watch that I guess
if you gr up in the South it's a given
that it's about slavery to me it was
about but Freedom what do you do it's
it's bigger than slavery that was such a
stain on our
history but what do you take from it
going forward yes of course slavery is
never can never happen again but going
forward doesn't that mean
we should focus on the freedoms of
people to live their life not to have
government not to have any other person
tell them what they can and can't do
that's been trampled on the past few
years that's the part we got to make
sure we never take anything away from so
look I mean you guys can make it about
something else but if you look at my my
record in South Carolina we dealt with
this a whole lot more than and what I'll
tell you is yes you can acknowledge a
point in history but what do you do with
that point in history you got to make
sure the lessons constantly go forward
so that we never see it
again I mean that's mostly word salad
like if you were to look at a transcript
of what she just said it wouldn't you
wouldn't even know where to place
punctuation because it's so rambling and
nonsensical uh but she does at least say
that slavery shouldn't happen again so
we have her Nikki Haley breaks her
Silence about slavery uh and she is so
so now we know that she is in the uh she
does it she does oppose slavery she
doesn't want to reinstate slavery so
that's good because we weren't sure we
definitely weren't sure and um you know
it's all kind of funny because her
answers are so incredibly stupid and she
she kind of reminds me of that clip of
what was it the Miss America contestant
from like 15 years ago or or whatever
pageant it was trying to talk about
geography you know that Infamous clip so
she reminds me of that a little bit just
totally
clueless and that's what you're seeing
with Nikki Haley here uh everyone is
accusing her of refusing to mention
slavery because she's some kind of
Confederate sympathizer
and that is obviously not the case okay
and I'm not a a Nikki Haley Defender
myself but I I will
say even though I don't like Nikki Haley
I will say she's I I feel relatively
certain that she is not in favor of
slavery and she's also not a secret
Confederate sympathizer like I don't
think if you went to her house you would
find a room full of Confederate flags
and and memorabilia that she keeps in a
secret vault somewhere I I I I don't
think that
I mean she put herself on the map
politically by removing Confederate
flags from the South Carolina state
capital she she has long been a champion
of tearing down flags and statues she
worshiped at the BLM altar during George
George Floyd um so she would have no
problem giving the standard sort of
acceptable answer to that
question and uh you know saying that the
C Civil War is about slavery and nothing
else I I don't think she was trying to
Pander
to who knows what demographic I I don't
think that's what was happening there I
think she's just an
airhead and and that's it like the truth
is she she really doesn't know anything
about the Civil War so I think when she
when she was asked that question she
panicked not because she's afraid to
talk about slavery but but because she
she she she probably doesn't even know
what century the Civil War was fought in
and it's not just her by the way okay
it's like most politicians last year
because of you pre-born network of
clinics saved over 58,000 babies thank
you to all who made this possible uh
let's celebrate these precious
[Music]
babies my name is shanet I just want to
share a little experience with you
through my pregnancy I am 32 weeks
pregnant when I found out I was pregnant
I was 7 weeks um my pregnancy was an
unplanned situation I was unplanned but
my boyfriend he always needed a child
and abortion was in the back of my mind
but I know if I did if that would ruin
our relationship but doing my first
ultra sound seeing my baby girl moving
and here in the heartbeat it was so
overwhelming it was a joy for us both of
us were happy we're excited we can't
wait to welcome a baby girl into this
world and I want to thank mission
pre-born for the h Sone I thank you for
everything that you done that you have
done for us thank you so much and God
bless
[Music]
you when Charlotte found out she was
pregnant she was seven weeks along in
the back of her mind she thought
abortion was the best solution she went
into a pre-born clinic and after hearing
her baby's heartbeat and seeing her
beautiful baby on ultrasound she chose
life her heart is filled with gratitude
for all of you who made this possible
each of these babies are truly
miraculous and every day pre-born
celebrates 200 Miracles just $28 a month
can be the difference between the life
and death of a child when a mother meets
her baby on ultrasound and hears the
heartbeat it's a Divine connection that
doubles a baby's chance at life so let's
join together and help mothers choose
life to donate dial pound 250 and say
the keyword baby that's pound 250 say
the keyword baby or go to pre-born /at
that's pre-born dcomm mat think about
your favorite childhood memory that you
uh caught on film or videotape do you
have an easy way to watch it or share it
with friends and family if you're like
most people you probably don't and lucky
for you we have found a solution with
Legacy box Legacy box makes this easy to
do simply send your legacy box filled
with camcorder tapes film reels and
pictures get back digital copies that
can be easily enjoyed shared and
organized it's like magic it's that easy
Legacy box is the world's largest
digitized they've helped over 1 million
families relive their wedding days
chaotic childhood Christmases and even
road trips to Yellowstone and by going
to legacybox.com matat you can enjoy 50%
off when you get started with Legacy box
today kick off their New Year by uh
rescuing your family's most cherish
memories that haven't been watched or
enjoyed in years go to legacybox.com to
save 50% buy today send it in when
you're ready go to legacybox.com slat
that's legacybox.com
slat one thing you have to understand is
that most of our politicians not all of
them but most of them are are actually
very stupid these are not intelligent
people this is probably if we could do
an IQ test of everybody in in uh the
Senate right now and the the house
everyone in Congress let's say do an IQ
test I I doubt on average that they
break 85 okay so they're like barely
above room temperature with their
IQ and that's what you saw there this
it's not any secret thing where she's
racist no she just doesn't know she she
she was way over the moment someone
brought up Civil War she was way over
her skis and she knew it and that's why
she tried to Pivot back what do you
think I don't know what's your opinion
you know it's that classic tactic I
tried that myself when I was a kid and I
get a pop quiz and I ask a question by
my teacher I was said I don't what do
you think you tell me what your thoughts
I want to hear your thoughts first and
I'll let you
know um also being an establishment GOP
type she instinctively wants to tie
everything back to establishment GOP
talking points and that's why she went
on about the role of government and the
and freedom and
capitalism I mean the role of government
and capitalism had nothing to do with
the Civil War okay they were not
fighting over
capitalism but she ties it back to that
because those are the talking points and
uh it's all she knows and and this is
what they do this is the every every
question every
question is you're going to get
something about well you know the
government's too big government's too
big and when it's economic freedom lower
taxes
uh that's it that's all what you could
ask her like I don't know what's the
surface temperature of the Sun and
she'll give you something about the role
of government um all that
said most of her Critics on this issue
are
also wrong or at least not fully right
because everyone just wants her to say
that slavery was the cause was and
that's it as if that's all that can or
should be said about the Civil War but
like literally any other War that's ever
been fought anywhere on Earth for the
entirety of the history of human
civilization um it is more complicated
than that okay no war that's ever been
fought can be explained with a single
word it just doesn't the history of the
world doesn't work that way there's
always more to
it which doesn't mean mean we can't
identify good guys and bad guys I mean
some Wars you can some Wars you can't
depend mean you know we're talking about
a broad subject of War here but all I'm
saying is that um there has never been a
war so simple that if someone asks you
what caused it you could just give them
one word and that's
it um and with the Civil War there was
more to it I mean obviously slavery was
a significant factor but the division
between the North and the South ran
deeper than that but I think more
importantly
and this is the important distinction
for me when it comes to this civil war
in history of the Civil War and the
causes the motivations rather really um
this is the most important distinction
and this is
also the point that should come into
play when we're talking about you know a
statue of Roberty Lee or something and
whether we should tear it down and we
shouldn't and the reason that we
shouldn't is that there is a distinction
to be made in every war but especially
in the civil war between the
political macro level
causes and the personal motivations of
the people doing the fighting
so in the macro slavery was a central
cause of the Civil
War was a well established historical
fact individually however the men who
did the
fighting did not consider themselves to
be fighting over slavery
on either side for the most part and
especially in the
beginning um The Men Who marched down
from the
north were were as far as they were
concerned were not going to war to to
free the
slaves most of them would not have taken
up arms for that
purpose um and the men fighting in the
South were certainly not going to war as
far as they were concerned to keep
slaves considering that almost none of
them had slaves I mean the men who were
doing the fighting these were Poor Farm
boys that like most of them didn't have
shoes okay they didn't have
slaves and uh they weren't they weren't
out there bleeding and dying to protect
uh the you know uh farmer Jim's
Plantation down the street and the SL
like that's not what they were that's
not what moves people to fight um and to
die in such desperate
situations uh you the men from the north
thought of themselves as fighting to
preserve the union and the men from the
south thought of themselves as fighting
to defend their Homeland and if you were
to ask them if you were to go back in a
time machine to
1861 and go up and you know walk onto
the battlefield which I wouldn't
recommend and uh ask any of the
Confederate soldiers why they're
fighting that's probably the answer they
would
give they they probably would not say we
want to keep slaves they would say
something like I'm defending my home
this is my
home Robert Le
famously uh decided to fight for the
South rather than uh you know being a
commander in the north and he made that
decision not because he wanted to keep
slaves but because from his
perspective he needed to defend his home
and he considered his home to be
Virginia more than you know if he were
to think about what's my home it would
be the state of Virginia not the United
States as a whole that's the way he saw
it that's the way he thought of it
that's the way most people thought of it
back in those
days and that's and and what I'm talking
about right now is not some like deep
uh brilliant Insight this is just the
general understanding that that in the
Insight of of like that most people have
understood for you
know almost since the world war was
fought and and that's why most people up
until recently have not had much of a
problem with statue of Rob Lee the
building named after him because they
were able to separate even if they
wouldn't have explained it in quite
these terms they were able to separate
the macropolitical causes from the the
men
themselves um and they were able to
understand that uh that this was not a
you know this was not a cartoon being
fought this was not a cartoon these were
not you know uh uh
cartoonish
villains um these were human beings
and their motivations and what drove
them was far more complex than uh what
we like to pretend
today so anyway Nikki Haley could have
said something like that um but uh I
guess I'm not surprised that she didn't
hey YouTube thanks for listening to the
show if you'd like access to my full
show with no ads you should go to
dailywire.com and use promo code Walsh
to get two months free on all annual
plans see you there